welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and what is up with the moon in all
of these thor love and thunder
promotional materials huh the moon
appears to be a prominent part of this
movie as the posters and trailer footage
seem to have been focused around gore's
mysterious plans for what i believe to
be earth's moon why could this be well i
think that i may have just realized why
we've been seeing so much moon [ __ ] in
this movie and it could spell some big
time moon doom for every single god that
has ever existed in the mcu yes even
frogman the greatest god of our time so
let us dive into what this could be
together my nerd babies but first you
should dive into newrockstarsmerch.com
to pick up our latest obsession shirt
inspired by miss marvel it is one of the
coolest shirts ever in my opinion and
it's i think it's really cool because i
really love this marvel so you can buy a
shirt for miss marvel or you can even
buy one for obi-wan kenobi those shirts
are not gonna last forever so pick one
up today at new rockstarsmerch.com like
i said something is up with the moon in
thor love and thunder and i think the
reason for this could be because gore
the godbutcher is intending on building
the ultimate weapon to use against all
the gods in the universe a weapon that
could even explode across time itself to
kill every god that has ever lived and
ever will live that's right everybody
i'm talking about the god bomb the
ultimate goal for gore the god butcher
during his first comic run on the pages
of gore god of thunder because in the
comics gore the god butcher realizes
that although butchering gods one by one
with his trusty necro sword 24 7 was
indeed a six flags time it's not
necessarily the most efficient way to
kill all the gods in the universe
because much like the mad titan and the
black order resorted to using the
infinity stones to wipe out half of life
in the mcu so they could stop needing to
commit genocide with armies and whatnot
or the god butcher knows that if he is
ever going to retire to his godless
paradise universe he needs to find some
type of cosmic way to get rid of all the
gods at once and so in order to do this
war the god butcher needed to use slave
labor from hundreds and hundreds of gods
that he decided not to butcher to build
a massive moon sized bomb made from the
remnants of two moons and just how did
gore the god butcher get to the very
beginning of time you ask well he
murdered all the time gods that lived on
the planet chronics and took a dip in
their famous pool of forevers of course
a pool that gore would decide to
incorporate into the very center of his
moon-sized god bomb so that's when he
triggered the bomb with his all-black
necrosword little pieces of all black
would splash themselves throughout all
of time and embed themselves within each
and every god that ever existed and
slowly and painfully kill them this is
the ultimate goal of gore the god
butcher when he first appeared in the
first 11 issues of gore god of thunder
in 2013 and one i believe that 4-4 will
be adapting in its own way possibly with
a gore the god of butcher needing to use
the moon of mcu earth to make his god
bomb dreams a reality and the reason why
i'm convinced that the moon that we're
seeing in all the four promo materials
that shows what i believe to be earth's
moon at the very top of the poster
symbolically surrounding thor in a
little halo while our heroes stand in
front of what appears to be a monument
to odin that asgard erected at the
norwegian cliff where odin died in thor
ragnarok as evidenced by behind the
scenes pictures of thor 4 that we've had
for a while making me believe that this
poster is set on the very same cliff in
norway with earth's moon overhead
implied as a supposed target for our
frustrated god butcher so this all being
said earth could very well face the
direct consequences of gore's own
personal vendetta against the gods
through the direct detonation of earth's
moon through gore's god bomb and even if
the detonation doesn't ultimately affect
most of the lives of the mortal beings
of the universe the people of earth
would most likely suffer greatly because
of their moon's destruction and mcu gore
making a god bomb to destroy all the
gods throughout time and space makes a
ton of sense considering that thor's
brother loki just broke the sacred
timeline an act that according to marvel
studios head kevin feige allowed for the
interdimensional timeline hopping
shenanigans in both no way home and
multiverse of madness because according
to feige after he who remains let the
timeline go crazy pretty much all the
rules of time have been thrown out the
damn window which now opens the door for
gore to destroy every single god in
every single branch of the mcu
multiverse at once giving him the
ultimate victory like no more gods in
the mcu multiverse period which would be
amazing because this would mean that
loki would probably have to reunite with
his brother to stop this because a
multiversal threat like gore's god bomb
would directly affect loki too but that
is the role i believe the moon will
serve in for love and thunder what do
you guys think let us know in the
comment section below but thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] but most importantly you can follow
new rockstars wherever we are on social
media and when you do it on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every single time
we upload a video hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com if you want to
support us these shirts are amazing and
they're not going to last forever like i
always say so hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com today while it's here
but again thank you guys so much for
watching this video i love you guys
tremendously and i hope you guys have an
amazing day goodbye
[Music]
you